you better have plan b in case your good
running back goes down or your whole
team's ruined and the way you attack is
so that was a smart pick by you know
spielman and zimmer and company there
were two teammates last year who rushed
for a thousand yards who are they hurry
up figure this out two teammates
jeez hurry up this is easy lamar jackson
and markings oh good job way to go under
the pressure boom all right take your
little minnesota vikings okay
but oh here you go but let me tell you
this
let me tell you this what the the next
time i ask you the trivia question i'm
not gonna shut up i'm gonna needle you
and i'm gonna say let's go let's go
let's go we're running out of time let's
go
all right uh can i take lamar jackson
and mark ingram no you cannot they're
not running backs you jerked
don't you do it
not bad for a running back he said so
himself all right uh i'm i'm gonna start
taking your advice in baltimore i'm not
i'm not i'm not because i am
trying to see the future christopher not
the present all due respect to dalvin
cook and alexander madison i see the
future in baltimore and i see mark
ingram and i see jk dobbins and i see a
special season for those two especially
with lamar jack and there's well and i
know there's only one football but
there's that that that jk dobbins pick
resonated with me at a visceral level
and he may just send mark ingram to the
sideline for good he may just take over
but i i love what ingram still has in
the tank i love what he brings to the
table the support for lamar jackson the
leadership as a veteran you add jk
dobbins to the mix and i think those two
are going to emerge as the best running
back tandem this year in the nfl
especially as maybe they try to protect
lamar jackson a little bit more i think
so from getting injured by running the
ball let the two running backs run the
ball let lamar jackson stay behind the
line of scrimmage and throw the ball
yeah i would expect that you know like
him to be a little bit more of a decoy
this year in the run game and you just
run them maybe in certain situations
where they feel like hey we need to or
this is a great look or whatever mike i
mean i'm i mean this i'm with i'm about
as excited about this running back duo
as there isn't any in football i mean i
mean it's it's mark ingram the
sledgehammer up the middle arguably hits
the hole as hard as anybody in football
and you got to worry about that and then
whoa if jk dobbins is in the backfield
along with ingram and lamar you have to
worry about like jk dobbins is a home
run hitter he is a guy that is going to
be able to go around the edge against
any defensive football and run for an 80
and 85 yard touchdown he is special that
way so i i mean i'm not mad at you there
that's a good damn pick all right i'll
go with the vikings then i'll take your
team i'll take your running backs
i think that's what i'm gonna go with i
mean it's a damn good dubo i can't deny
that i'm not gonna argue against chuck
foreman i mean i agree you've been
saying it since last year
what chuck said
yeah alexander madison starting for a
lot of teams in football a lot i mean
you saw just from that highlight like
this explosion their size there's
physicality and dalvin cook
he's as good as it gets in the game too
so i i mean to me that is certainly one
of the best duos in football
yeah look i agree with you on that and
and i didn't want to be
like too predictable and i and i do
believe if you know if you could say
take uh mark ingram and j.k dobbs and
put them on the viking instead of
cooking madison i think that's a pretty
good trade right now here's a
potentially even better trade and i'm
surprised you didn't land on these two
chris because we didn't see much from
kareem hunt
i just did you know i didn't know what
to do
kareem hunt was the nfl rushing leader
in 2017 as a rookie nick chubb had it in
hand last year until derek henry went
crazy down the stretch and just blew him
away nick chubb and kareem hunt in
cleveland now again i'm concerned about
the there's only one football dynamic
there because of the passing game and
odell beckham jr and jarvis landry but
still running back combination best duo
chub and hunt i tell you what i may have
taken them before cook and madison i
have gotten my top two picks here i i
trust me i thought about it i did you
know i really was yeah i expected you to
take the vikings and i was probably
going to take the brown second af after
that i i thought so you messed up my
thoughts there but i guess the only
thing that led me not to is just it's
you know kareem hunt hasn't got totally
back in the full swing of things since
the suspension and all that i'm just not
sure yeah how that roll fits out now you
know
oddly enough they're going to be playing
minnesota's offense so
whatever you saw with dalvin cook and
madison you're gonna see something
similar there with these two but i'm
with you i mean nick chubb does not get
enough credit for being one of the best
running backs in the game and kareem
hunt like you said we know uh he can be
one of the best running backs in the
game and i would think his role ex
expands a lot this year especially in
passing situations
all right damn you're annoying i can't
believe you picked those two um all
right
i am so i just totally thought i was
gonna get the browns and you weren't to
think about the weekend wobbly against
the ropes i'm going broncos though i got
to go broncos here i mean
that's my next pick with with with
gordon and phillip lindsey it's a great
combination of size and power in melvin
gordon and melvin gordon can go too now
he's a guy that can take a a touchdown
50 60 yards to the house it's that's
rare for somebody his size and then
phillip lindsey i mean we don't have
much to say about that he's like a jk
dobbins he's got two rockets up his butt
he can turn the corner or split any hole
and take it to the house and make people
miss in space so i look at those two as
being one of the more dangerous
combinations in football too uh melvin
gordon doesn't get the respect he
deserves and you know i think with that
offense shurmur running the ball mike
munchek we've talked about the weapons
they have it's almost a little bit of
the same problem you talk about the
browns is there enough balls to go
around to all these guys you know there
in denver but that's certainly one of
the better running back duos
you know from time to time i say to my
wife that
when it's time to stand before the
pearly gates and st peter decides who
gets in and who doesn't
is it possible that the husband and wife
average each other out because she's got
more than enough to get in and maybe
together
like i i can you know some of that
sorry and we both sorry that doesn't
work i'm i'm counting on jill's going in
they're gonna be like hey can you wait
out here we have to uh look at your
credentials again in your resume we're
not sure yet
and i say that i say that because best
running back duo doesn't necessarily
have to be both guys are great it could
be one guy is so great and the other guy
is good here he goes potentially great
well what do you think i'm doing what's
the thing i'm taking uh i i
i thought christian mccaffrey and
whoever or
or maybe
knew what he did close ezekiel elliott
and tony pauler okay cowboys top two
running backs okay because they combined
for over 1800 rushing yards last year
and it was a down year for zeke and it
was a rookie year for pollard pollard's
gonna be better this year zeke's gonna
be better this year and again it's
another situation where she got three
receivers talking about having a
thousand yards each and and maybe the
cowboys are just gonna have six thousand
yards from scrimmage this year and
everybody gets their thousand but i i
think that that zeke and pollard
together
and zeke carrying a little more of the
load than pollard but together i'll take
them hey i actually think it's a good
pick i thought you were going to go you
know something more like the giants or
something like just go like saquon and
be whoever's there with them they're a
great duo but no tony pollard
there's something to him you know
averaged over five yards per carry last
year i mean there was a few times where
i went damn i wish he was in the game
rather than zeke with that hole because
i think he could have maybe had a little
more of a home run effect as we talk
about but i think that's a very under
the radar really good pick by you way to
go i mean not much you know not often
that you're smart but that one was smart
um
uh
all right i'm going with the rookies too
i'm going rookie i was gonna go 49ers
and kevin coleman and and raheem moster
but i think i'm more what about jared
mckinnon mckinnon may be better than
either you're right i just don't know i
haven't seen him in two years so i can't
throw that out there but i think i'm
gonna go marlon mack and jonathan taylor
more over that i am i mean marlo marlon
mack healthy
is a really damn good running back
jonathan taylor i mean i'm taking your
page from jk dobbins i think he's going
to end up being the the workhorse there
and he has a superstar factor to him
he's built out of granite he can fly he
can break tackles and between behind
that offensive line and everything yeah
i think that's going to be a special duo
this year i do
and jonathan taylor one of the guys that
i interviewed at the combine while you
were
yeah out of commission right
he is going to be a star now i don't
know that indianapolis is going to be
the market that is going to best you
know showcase him to the entire national
football league he's got that
electricity to him he is going to be i
think he stands out whatever team he
plays for i think he's going to be a
star and he may quickly supersede marlon
mack all right that's our pick i had
carry on johnson and deandre swift as a
possibility right i thought about the
49ers plenty of great running back duos
out there at a time when the running
back position supposedly is devalued
there's a lot of guys who can get it
done
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports